mes chers collègues
c'est le président
en application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution
nous entendons ce matin Monsieur Robert
que nous avons jusqu'ici bien connu dans
d'autres fonctions nous y reviendrons
candidat proposé par le Président de la
République pour être nommé président de
l'Autorité des normes comptables en
remplacement de Patrick de Combourg que
nous avons aussi connu celui-ci ayant
été nommé président du conseil sur le
reporting de durabilité au sein de
l'ephrague c'est à dire de la structure
européenne qui court le sujet
est
issu de la fusion en 2009 du Conseil
national de la comptabilité et du Comité
de la réglementation comptable cette
autorité intervient dans la
détermination des règles comptables
nationales et représente la France
auprès des instances internationales
chargées de l'élaboration des normes
comptables
international
ainsi l'autorité donne un avis
ainsi mes chers collègues l'autorité
donne un avis sur toute disposition
législative ou réglementaire contenant
des mesures de nature comptable et elle
établit en vue de leur homologation par
le ministre chargé de l'économie les
règlements comptables applicables aux
entreprises depuis l'année dernière un
comité sur l'information de durabilité
des entreprises
a également été formé au sein de l'ANC
chargé de répondre aux consultations
européennes et internationale sur le
sujet il s'agit à titre principal de se
doter d'une formation pour travailler
aux réponses à l'ephragues dans le cadre
de la définition de l'Autorité
Européenne pour dire les choses dans le
cadre de la définition des informations
exiger les entreprises en application de
la directive sur le reporting de
durabilité des entreprises
cette audition est publique est
retransmis en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat en application de la
loi organique et de la loi ordinaire du
23 juillet 2010 relative à l'application
du cimetière alinéa de l'article 13 de
la Constitution c'est audition sera
suivie d'un vote qui se déroulera à
butin secret je rappelle que les
délégations de vote ne sont pas
autorisés le dépouillement sera effectué
après le vote votre audition par
l'Assemblée nationale c'est en déroulée
ce matin même en vertu du cinquième
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution le président de la
République ne pourrait procéder à cette
nomination si l'addition de votre
négatif exprimée dans les deux
commissions représentées au total au
moins trois cinquième des suffrages
exprimés je vous laisse la parole pour
un propos introductif puis je donnerai
la parole à notre collègue Antoine
Lefebvre qui a été désigné comme
rapporteur par notre commission
pour cette audition
j'ai offert merci merci infiniment
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président porteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs merci de modifier juste à la
sortie de l'Assemblée nationale
ce qui donne dynamique à cette process
donc en effet le président de la
République m'a pressenti pour présider
l'Autorité des normes comptables à la
suite de Patrick de Cambour votre
commission avait auditionné Patrick
decambour il y a deux ans dans le cadre
du renouvellement de sa à la près de son
renouvellement à la présidence de l'ANC
je peux vous indiquer que évidemment ma
présidence si vous la confirmiez
s'inscrirait dans la continuité de ce
que Patrick de Cambour vous avez alors
présenté
je vais évoquer ce matin en propos
introductif l'émission de l'ANC les
défis qu'elle doit relever et indiquer
si possible comment elle pourrait être à
la hauteur de ces de ces défis et vous
donner quelques peut-être quelques
éléments rapides sur mes qualifications
pour y contribuer
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
l'autorité d'un homme comptable
à trois types de missions qui lui ont
été confiées par par l'ordonnance de
janvier 2009
une une première type de premier type de
mission ce sont les règles les normes
comptables nationales c'est-à-dire
réglement prescription comptable général
et sectorielle que doit respecter les
personnes physiques ou morales qui
doivent élaborer des documents
comptables conformes aux normes de
comptabilité privée et dans le
prolongement de cela elle donne aussi un
avis sur les dispositions législatives
ou réglementaires qui contiennent des
mesures de nature comptable applicables
même personne le deuxième
grand mission c'est
donner des émettre de sa propre
initiative ou à la demande des ministres
des avis est prise de position dans le
cadre des procédures d'élaboration des
normes comptables internationales
deuxième dimension internationale et
troisième dimension qui est quelque part
à l'appui de tout cela c'est coordonner
et faire la synthèse des travaux
théoriques et méthodologiques dans en
matière comptable c'est la recherche en
matière de comptabilité comment est-ce
que l'ANC doit être un acteur important
pour assurer le développement de cette
recherche c'est rajouter récemment et
l'information extra-financière à fournir
et qui est désormais normalisé de façon
de plus en plus forte dans la sous
l'appellation d'information de
durabilité et à la demande du ministre
la NC a donc couvert ce domaine qui est
si vous le souhaitez très complémentaire
des informations financières
avec ce ce comité de l'information de
durabilité en fait de même que nous
avons au niveau international sous la
Fondation IFRS de jambes
comptables
comptabilité financière et l'issb
information durabilité maintenant nous
avons au niveau européen au niveau de
l'ephrague nous avons un comité sur
l'information durabilité et pardon nous
avons oui un comité sur l'information de
durabilité et un comité sur le reporting
financier de même en France nous avons
vocation à couvrir ces deux ces deux C2
branches la transposition de la
directive CSRD en donne une opportunité
d'inscrire cette mission dans la loi j'y
reviendrai parce que précisément vous
avez eu des débats déjà sur cette
transposition
l'ANC est ne nous y trompons pas c'est
d'abord le normalisateur comptable
français
pour environ 5 millions d'entités qui
suivent les normes nationales pour
établir leur compte sociaux le dynamisme
dans cette dans l'exercice de cette
mission fonde sa légitimité et la fonde
au-delà même du cadre national parce que
c'est cela qui aussi lui donne un écho à
l'international au-delà du travail que
j'appellerai de courant d'actualisation
des normes françaises en fonction des
nouveaux instruments et des nouvelles
circonstances qui arrivent régulièrement
la question se pose de poursuivre de
conclure ou d'engager des travaux plus
ambitieux je pense à certaines approches
sectorielles par exemple dans les
secteurs financiers la banque et
l'assurance qui ont des des normes les
normes françaises sont un peu anciennes
dans ces dans ces domaines là
et et pas toujours très
adapta toujours actualiser en fonction
des pratiques et je pense également au
développement d'une approche plus
principale du plan comptable général
plan qui a été dans la Constitution a
fait l'objet d'un travail très très
important par la NC mais qui a été fait
à à règles constante et on en lit et on
en mesure les limites normatives
lorsqu'on le compare aux approches
internationales ce travail principal a
été engagé par la NC mais les débats
autour de la notion de chiffre
d'affaires illustre la difficulté d'une
telle démarche avec notamment la
nécessité de surmonter les difficultés
liées à la nécessaire cohérence entre
l'approche comptable et l'approche
fiscale on le sait le système français
est un système qu'on appelle moniste ce
sont les comptes sociaux qui constituent
la base de détermination du résultat
imposable des entreprises et on en
traduisant la réalité économique de
l'activité de réalité les normes
comptables ne devraient pas conduire à
des divergences significatives avec
l'approche fiscale renforcer cette
connexion fiscale au comptable doit donc
rester un axe de travail majeur pour
l'Autorité des normes comptables une
telle démarche ne peut être fructueuse
qu'en réunissant toutes les parties
prenantes l'administration fiscale bien
entendu mais aussi les entreprises et
les entreprises des plus petites qui
elles sont très attachées à la
convergence et à la stabilité des normes
à des fins de sécurité des juridiques et
qui souhaitent une simplification de ses
normes au plus grande qui elle
établissent aussi leur compte consolider
selon le référentiel comptable
international de l'IASB que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et qui cherchent elles
plutôt une convergence entre les règles
applicables à leurs comptes annuels
sociaux et celles de leur compte
consolidés parce que cela correspond
pour elle aussi à une simplification
opérationnelle simplification ne
signifie pas la même chose pour une
petite entreprise et pour une très
grande entreprise et il faut donc
prendre tout cela en compte ça me
conduit naturellement et évoquer les
normes internationales qui s'appliquent
obligatoirement au compte consolider des
entreprises de l'Union qui sont cotés
sur un marché réglementé soit environ
500 entreprises en France il faut avoir
l'ordre de grandeur 5 millions d'entités
pour les normes françaises 500
comptes consolidés pour les normes
internationales
l'Union en effet décidé de ne pas
développer ses propres normes en matière
de comptabilité financière mais de
retenir les normes de li ASB qui sont
donc intégrés dans le cadre de la
réglementation européenne après une
procédure d'homologation qui se fait sur
avis de l'ephrague que vous avez évoqué
on peut exceptionnellement ça peut se
traduire par l'introduction d'options
alternatives spécifiquement européenne
ça arrive ce fut le cas récemment pour
la norme IFRS 17 sur les contrats
d'assurance avec la faculté ce qu'on
appelle le carvout de ne pas retenir
pour certains contrats une approche
encore à Noël qui met en mal le principe
de mutualisation des risques qui est une
des fondements de nos dispositifs
d'assurance
le challenge pour l'autorité des nombres
comptables et d'être efficace le plus en
amont possible via un dialogue nourri
avec l'IASB mais notre force de
conviction n'est naturellement d'autant
plus forte que nos positions sont
partagées par nos partenaires de l'Union
parce que si on arrive uni dans l'Union
li asbc que l'Union est infinie le
principal utilisateur de ces normes et
donc ça pèse beaucoup plus que si on est
tout seul les débats au sein de les
frags sont donc aussi essentiels pour
peser sur l'élaboration des normes ASB
et éviter d'avoir à s'engager dans la
voie qui est toujours délicate du
carvout de l'exception
en au dernier moment
si on peut considérer qu'en matière de
normes comptables internationale
l'essentiel a été fait ou est clôturé en
pensant particuliers à l'amortissement
des surveilleurs qui a été une nouvelle
fois écartée du paysage des dossiers
sensibles restent en cours ainsi la
présentation des états financiers
eux-mêmes va relever d'une norme qui est
en cours de finalisation de même le
renforcement des informations à fournir
dans le cadre des tests de dépréciation
est à l'étude et fait suite d'une
certaine manière à l'abandon de l'idée
d'introduire un amortissement des
surveilleurs que j'évoquais à l'instant
et puis il y a des revues périodiques
des
prières à Ali ASB donc des revues
périodiques à venir sur des normes qui
ont été récemment mis en oeuvre sans
être porteuse de changement majeur ces
revues appellent une attention soutenue
parce que une des prochaines revues
c'est quoi la norme de chiffre
d'affaires
l'ifrs15 donc quelque chose qui est
quand même très très sensible ni faut
que tu sais qu'est-ce difficile à faire
et aussi celui des contrats de location
l'ifrss qui a introduit des
modifications très substantielles dans
tous ces travaux nous devons favoriser
la pertinence de l'approche et
promouvoir la qualité de l'information
donnée au tiers mais il faut également
je crois mesurer l'incidence de la norme
sur la compétitivité de nos acteurs
économiques l'approche de la Fondation
IFRS privilégie souvent les
investisseurs
j'allais dire les marchés en leur
procurant des informations les plus
détaillées possibles la proche
américaine est d'ailleurs assez
paradoxalement plus mesuré que
l'approche
ISB il peut donc y avoir un déséquilibre
concurrentiel avec des niveaux
hétérogènes de détails sur des
informations concernant la marche des
affaires des entreprises visées il
convient donc d'être vigilant pour
garder le bon équilibre et éviter de
rendre public de façon inappropriée des
informations commercialement ou
juridique sensible
nous devons traiter désormais le sujet
de nouveau et lourd de la normalisation
extra-financière dans le cadre de la
directive CSRD et des travaux de l'issb
au niveau international les défis sont
nombreux dans ce domaine d'abord il faut
finaliser le cadre normatif européen et
assurer sa bonne déclinaison
mise en oeuvre en France et ensuite
assurer au minimum sa compatibilité avec
les normes internationales et avec les
normes nationales de nos principaux
partenaires je vais revenir brièvement
sur ces deux aspects
premier aspect donc les énormes CSRD
elle-même la France a joué un rôle
moteur pour développer une normalisation
européenne ambitieuse dans ce domaine
ambitieuse et je vous en donnais
quelques éléments parce que il faut
qu'on ait tous conscience qu'il s'agit
d'une évolution extrêmement lourde par
rapport à tout ce que l'on connaît cette
ambitieux parce qu'elle court elle
permet de couvrir clairement et de
homogène dans l'Union les trois champs
environnement social gouvernance là où
certains se limitent encore à
l'environnement voire même au climat en
effet par exemple
issb en est encore à finaliser
uniquement ces normes concernant le
climat dont on attend la finalisation
au mois de mars prochain elle a une
dimension prospective ce n'est pas juste
une photo à l'instant donné puisqu'il
est demandé une description des
objectifs a sorti d'échéance que c'est
fixé l'entreprise en matière de
durabilité c'est une approche qui prend
en compte
tant pour l'environnement que pour le
social le concept de double matérialité
c'est à dire matérialité financière et
matérialité d'impact et il le fait sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur et pas
uniquement sur le périmètre de la
comptabilité financière les fournisseurs
les clients
ça couvre donc les besoins de l'ensemble
des partis prenantes et pas seulement
celle intéressée sur les risques pesant
sur la valeur de l'entreprise elle a ici
un périmètre qui va très au-delà des
entités d'intérêt public mais ce qu'on
appelle les e.ip qui sont en fait en
gros les sociétés cotées sur un marché
réglementé les banques et les assurances
dès lors qu'elles ont plus de 500 500
personnes
en effective parce qu'elle va couvrir de
façon obligatoire l'ensemble des grandes
entreprises au sens des définitions
européennes et ça ça veut dire pour
simplifier les entreprises qui ont des
effectifs moyens de plus de 250
personnes qu'elle soit côté ou pas et
donc on est sur un périmètre d'environ
8000 entreprises on est plus du tout on
est dans un autre dimension
cela permet d'ailleurs ça va couvrir de
fait très grande partie de nos activités
économiques probablement proche des deux
tiers enfin il faut avoir ça en tête et
par ailleurs je prends mon ancienne
casquette de président de la MF ça ne
constitue donc pas une incitation
supplémentaire pour des sociétés à se
retirer des marchés réglementés puisque
qu'elles soient ou non sur un marché
réglementé et bien elles devront fournir
ces informations elle prévoit aussi
cette réglementation un mécanisme
d'assurance d'audit sur les informations
de durabilité dans une première étape ce
n'est qu'une assurance limitée mais
l'étape de l'assurance raisonnable
c'est-à-dire le même niveau d'assurance
que celui qui est sur les données
financières et bien il est d'ores et
déjà prévu et tout cela sera encadré
dans l'union de façon homogène enfin
elle a une dimension excusez-moi d'être
un peu mais c'est vraiment une quelque
chose qui bouleverse elle a une
dimension extraterritoriale puisqu'elle
imposera les règles de l'Union aux
entités de pays tiers qui ont une
activité
significative dans l'Union
elle avait fait un cette directive
l'objet d'un accord en triloxe ou
présidente française au premier semestre
de l'an passé elle est bien d'être
publiée elle a été publié au Journal
officiel de l'Union européenne le 16
décembre et mais pour la mettre en œuvre
il y a un centre de diligence et en
particulier il y a deux choses à
faire il y a à aller
transposer cette disposition cette
directive dans les 27 ordres juridiques
nationaux et si possible la transposer
la plus rapidement possible puisque
comme je l'indiquais nous avons une
application dès les comptes de 2024 qui
seront certes avec des informations qui
sont publiées en 2025 mais sur les
comptes 2024 et
donc il y a une certaine il y a une il y
a une certaine urgence
donc il y a transposition et puis
finalisation des de ce qu'on appelle le
niveau 2 de la réglementation européenne
c'est à dire toutes les normes
techniques qui en fait sont permettent
d'opérationnaliser cette cette
réglementation
de fait c'est énorme technique sont
proposées par les phrases elles sont
proposées par les fraggues et après un
certain nombre de de vérifications
d'avis diverses et variées et bien elles
sont elles sont vocation à être prises
par la Commission européenne avec une
possibilité nonobjection des
collégislateurs à cette date 12 projets
de normes couvrant tous les aspects
nécessaires pour la mise en oeuvre en
janvier 2024 12 projets de normes ont
été proposés présentées par par les
frags et il y a donc ils vont
probablement sous une forme ou sous une
autre être mise en œuvre accepter
entériner autour de du milieu de cette
année si possible avant le 30 juin il
restera à fournir des normes
sectorielles des normes concernant les
PME et des normes pour les
établissements de pays tiers cet effort
considérable de normalisation mobilisera
les forces vives de la place
spécialement lorsqu'il s'appliquera à
l'ensemble des grandes entreprises que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la première
étape c'est ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
couverts par les obligations de DPF mais
la seconde étape qui vient très vite
puisque c'est l'exercice 2025 donc juste
une année de décalage là il faut il faut
mobiliser l'ensemble des forces vives de
la place pour qu'on puisse la mettre en
oeuvre de façon efficace ça veut dire et
vis-à-vis des entreprises et aussi
vis-à-vis de ceux qui auront à à
prononcer des
d'assurance modérée puis raisonnable sur
ces indications donc
tout tout l'audit est externe
nombre de nos entreprises ont une
activité qui dépasse le périmètre de
l'Union il importe que les normes
qu'elles auront à impliquées dans
l'Union soit compatible et proportionnée
avec celle que peuvent imposer d'autres
juridictions il faut en fait éviter les
les approches multiples et assurer une
concurrence équilibrée dans ce domaine
là cela passe d'abord par la
compatibilité et la proportionnalité
avec les normes internationales qui sont
en cours d'élaboration par l'issb
première norme sur le climat donc pour
fin mars
ce qui est recherché puisque l'issb sa
vocation à ce stade c'est de
déterminer une base commune
d'information
les différentes autorités nationales les
reprenant et pouvant en rajouter donc ce
que l'on recherche c'est de dire si vous
appliquez les normes européennes
automatiquement ça veut dire que vous
êtes compatible avec les normes de
l'issb
mais naturellement
les normes internationales de l'issb
ce qui est important c'est de qui va les
retenir qui valait qui va les prendre
qui va les retenir qui va les imposer
dans sa propre juridiction et là à ce
stade nous n'en savons rien ou plutôt
nous savons que les États-Unis ne le
feront pas soyons clairs les États-Unis
ne le feront pas ils ont développé une
approche qui est en cours de de
validation à travers la SICI le
l'autorité de de marcher américaine mais
on connaît les débats compliqués sur le
sujet dans aux États-Unis et donc ça
veut dire d'ailleurs que je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure en évoquant l'issb ce qui
est recherché
on n'aura pas la réciproque c'est à dire
que les gens qui appliquent les normes
ISSD ne seront pas reconnus comme
équivalent pour appliquer les normes
européennes les normes les gens qui
appliqueront les normes américaines s'il
y en a un jour ne seront pas retenus
comme équivalent par rapport aux normes
européennes parce que dans le CSRD il a
été très clairement dit que
l'équivalence qui comme prévu qui est
prévu ne peut s'appliquer que si les
normes de pays tiers couvrent l'ensemble
des facteurs environnementaux sociaux et
de gouvernance et si elle respecte le
principe de double matérialité et donc
aucune des normes que je viens d'évoquer
internationale ou
américaines ne respectent ces critères
là comment
comment relever tous ces défis la clé me
semble être d'abord de bien structurer
l'organisation de la place pour élaborer
des positions argumentées mesurer les
conséquences des diverses options mettre
en évidence les difficultés
d'application proposer les
clarifications utiles l'ANC l'Autorité
des normes comptables et le lieu
d'échange privilégié entre les
entreprises et toutes leurs parties
prenantes
identifié ça ce sont les outils d'une
telle mobilisation et les participations
aux autres travaux des autres autorités
l'AMF la CPR en particulier renforce la
cohérence des approches pour poursuivre
s'agit donc de poursuivre et d'amplifier
cette dynamique et pour se faire il nous
faut effectivement
disposer des ventes agents d'une équipe
permanente d'experts de haut niveau qui
est capable d'animer les groupes de
travail parce que quand j'évoquais des
groupes de travail représentant toutes
les parties prenantes de la place il
faut qu'il y ait un point fixe de
secrétariat d'animation qui est un
expert de l'autorité il nous faut
dépasser le cercle des très grandes
entreprises car on le voit qu'il
s'agisse des normes françaises
aujourd'hui ou demain des reportings de
durabilité le périmètre des sociétés
concernées va très au-delà de celui des
très grandes entreprises donc il faut
être attentif au maximum j'évoquais les
PME tout à l'heure parce que c'est
optionnel pour les PME en fait mais
l'optionnalité je pense que
l'optionnalité elle sera peut-être
remplie et il faut souhaiter qu'elle le
soit parce que ce sont des informations
utiles et donc tout ça signifie que il
faut être avoir un une écoute des
entreprises qui va très au-delà des très
grandes entreprises il nous faut une
coordination très forte avec les autres
autorités nationales y compris
l'administration fiscale pour limiter au
maximum les demandes reconditionnels ou
parallèles avec nous pensons que les
informations fournies par les états
comptables et le reporting de durabilité
doivent permettre de couvrir la
quasi-totalité des besoins de tout le
monde et donc n'en rajoutons pas
utilisant les informations qui sont là
il nous faut également soutenir une
recherche comptable ambitieuse c'est une
des missions de l'ANC et il faut être
vraiment
très attentif à ce sujet là parce que on
ne tente en particulier au niveau
international c'est vraiment en
s'appuyant sur une recherche de qualité
qu'on gagne le des idées et donc c'est
un c'est un domaine qui doit être tout à
fait en haut de nos objectifs il nous
faut ancrer je le crois la loi dans la
dans la loi la mission de l'Autorité des
normes comptables concernant les normes
d'information de durabilité des
entreprises qui résultent aujourd'hui
d'une d'un simple courrier du ministre
cela permettra d'asseoir l'autorité de
l'ANC dans ce secteur que qui va
vraiment structurer les travaux de tous
l'écosystème et étroitement lié aux
normes comptables j'y reviendrai si vous
voulez il nous faut élaborer enfin un
nouveau plan stratégique détaillé sur
nos priorités pour les trois prochaines
années je m'y attacherai avec le nouveau
collège si vous confirmez ma nomination
aujourd'hui je serai prudent sur un
certain nombre de d'axes parce que
fondamentalement un plan stratégique
c'est pas un plan personnel c'est un
plan d'un collège d'une adhésion et ce
collège représente beaucoup les parties
prenantes de la place il est important
de que
une stratégie permettent justement
d'amorcer cette dynamique que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
je vais être très bref sur mes qualités
éventuelles pour assumer cette
présidence et être à la hauteur des
enjeux que je viens d'évoquer
l'intégralité de mon de mon parcours
professionnel a été réalisé dans le
secteur public j'ai rejoint la Banque de
France immédiatement la fin de mes
études diplôme de l'ESSEC et diplôme
d'études comptables supérieure je
rejoins la Banque de France en février
81 je l'ai quitté en août 2017 pour
rejoindre l'Autorité des marchés
financiers en assurer la présidence avec
un mandat de 5 ans non renouvelable je
ne suis pas un professionnel de la
comptabilité mais j'ai accumulé au cours
de ces de cette carrière je crois de
connaissances en la matière et j'ai eu
en particulier au cours des 10 dernières
années des interactions vraiment
fréquentes avec l'ANC je passais 8 ans
au contrôle des institutions financières
qui a qui ont
composante comptable extrêmement
significative et qui a vraiment évolué
d'ailleurs au cours du temps puisque ces
8 ans c'est c'est deux ans et demi en
début de carrière et 5 ans et demi en
tant que sous gouverneur président pour
le compte du gouverneur de la CPR j'ai
passé une dizaine d'années à la
direction financière de la Banque de
France à une époque où nous avons
normalisé les traitements comptables de
l'Institut des missions nous avons
introduit à ce moment-là d'ailleurs la
certification de nos comptes est
réformer notre système de retraite en
mettant en place un suivi rigoureux de
l'engagement de retraite puisque
l'engagement de retraite à la Banque de
France provisionnée en mettant en donc
sur la base des normes internationales
i.s19 en l'espèce la normalisation de la
banque de la comptabilité de la Banque
de France est passée aussi ensuite par
l'élaboration d'une approche comptable
commune entre les banques centrales de
l'Eurosystème afin de permettre
notamment le partage du revenu monétaire
j'en passe
il se trouve que c'est moi qui ai
conduit c'est c'est travaux pour le
compte de la Banque de France mais cinq
années à la présidente de la MF m'ont
plongé dans la communication financière
des émetteurs de titres donc
essentiellement sur la base des normes
internationales et FS à l'AMF ou à lesma
et aussi désormais à la communication
extra-financière sur la durabilité
à la MF à Esma et aussi et là c'est le
signal eiosco l'eau ICV qui est
l'organisme international beaucoup de
points communs ont été traités au cours
de ces cinq années avec avec la NC je
l'ai détaille pas je peux les détailler
si vous le souhaitez mais évidemment
quand on se pose la question de savoir
s'il est part de fonds communs de de
monétaire sont des équivalents de
trésorerie par exemple on voit bien par
exemple l'interaction qu'on peut avoir
ensemble ou quand il s'agit de traiter
des crypto actifs comment est-ce que ça
se passe donc je vais si vous voulez
m'arrêter et juste je voulais vous
signaler parce que pour moi c'est
important il se trouve que j'ai aussi
actuellement la responsabilité
du projet de piloter un peu le projet
français de candidature de Paris pour
accueillir la future autorité européenne
de lutte contre le blanchiment la
je le signale parce que
l'Union européenne est en train de
changer complètement de braquer dans ce
domaine là
elle elle est passée du niveau de la
directive qui était vaguement transposé
dans dans 27 pays au niveau d'une d'une
réglementation d'une qui s'applique de
façon automatique à l'ensemble des pays
et elle crée une nouvelle autorité et et
donc une nouvelle autorité qui aura
vocation sur l'ensemble du périmètre à
assurer l'homogénéité de la mise en
oeuvre de cette réglementation et avoir
de la supervision directe en matière de
de lutte antibiosiment d'une quarantaine
d'établissements financiers significatif
et et je le signale parce que je crois
qu'il faut qu'on se mette tous on est
tous prendre cette question à bras le
corps pour que ça soit efficace dans
l'Union merci
merci Monsieur
un rapport une présentation très
complète alors vous auriez pu peut-être
éviter la fin si je puis dire
présentation personnelle puisque nous
l'avons bien en tête et nous savons que
évidemment
votre passé pleine pour que cette
mission puisse être parfaitement remplie
par vous monsieur Lefebvre
en complément de la présentation de
Monsieur Opel je souhaite lui poser
quatre questions tout d'abord l'Autorité
des normes comptables est une autorité
un peu particulière dont la dotation
budgétaire portée par la Mission
économique est assez limitée de l'ordre
de 2 millions d'euros après l'Autorité
des marchés financiers vous prendriez
donc la tête d'une structure bien moins
imposante que je qualifierais de
plateformes de travail et d'échanges
considérez-vous qu'il serait nécessaire
de renforcer les moyens de l'ANC ou bien
l'autorité vous semble-t-elle parvenir
de façon satisfaisante à ses objectifs
avec les moyens dont elle dispose
puis je souhaite
évoquer la directive sur le reporting de
durabilité et des entreprises dites
c'est SRD elle aura bien sûr des
conséquences majeures sur les
obligations de publication
extra-financières des entreprises quel
est selon vous le rôle que dois-je jouer
la NC en matière de normalisation
extra-financière
par ailleurs considérez-vous que la
prise en compte des enjeux sociaux
écologiques doivent conduire des
évolutions des normes comptables
applicables aux informations financières
en effet la liaison entre informations
financière et informations non
financière me semble indispensable
Patrick decambour évoqué lui-même à ce
sujet une logique de fertilisation
croisée
enfin considérez-vous que l'Union
européenne et a fortiori la France se
sont assez
se sont pas assez représentés au sein de
l'ISB et que le cadre international et
l'homme comptable soit déterminé sur le
modèle anglo-saxon quels sont selon vous
les moyens de renforcer notre influence
et le nombre des représentants je vous
remercie
bien vous pouvez répondre il va
expliquer je vais prendre les deux
premiers qui sont complémentaires
puisqu'il s'agit de moyens financiers et
de moyens humains donc sans les moyens
je suis toujours prudent sur les moyens
parce que quelque part c'est très les
moyens un peu limités ça permet de se
concentrer sur ce qui est vraiment
prioritaire mais il faut être clair il
faut être clair j'ai évoqué une
vingtaine d'agents il faut c'est 21 il
faut cette vingtaine d'agents il faut
cette vingtaine d'agents et que ça soit
des des de bons de bon
de bons experts capables d'animer la
place parce que fondamentalement compte
tenu de la diversité des intérêts et des
partis prenantes ce n'est qu'en mettant
tous ces gens autour de la table qu'on
arrive à progresser et donc ça ça veut
dire que la NC n'a pas vocation à se
substituer à toutes ces à toutes à
toutes ces à toutes ces parties
prenantes par ailleurs la NC n'est pas
comme la meuf
n'a pas de rôle de supervision et tu
n'as pas de de filière répressives je je
donc on est sur sur des sur un
normalisateur et donc on doit avoir des
effectifs
qui sont cohérents avec cette fonction
mais mais pas mais mais on ne peut pas
comparer de mon point de vue avec
d'autres autorités qui ont une des
missions plus plus diverses alors il y a
les
l'Autorité des normes comptables n'est
pas une haie c'est une
c'est les moyens sont des moyens qui
entrent dans le cadre classique des
moyens du ministère de l'économie et des
finances à côté il y a un collège qui
avec là une un président qui est qui a
un mandat et donc qui est indépendant et
qui qui est avec le collège
pilote tout cela les fondamentalement
les moyens sont sont ceux que lui
donnent le ministère de l'économie et
des finances plus
un fond de concours un fond de concours
qui est alimenté par les entreprises et
les professionnels du chiffre
appelons-le comme ça cette
ce fond de concours essentiellement à
pour objet de financer les
organismes internationaux il y a SB
aujourd'hui et ephrague également
maintenant avec ephrag avec les deux
dimensions puisque on a rajouté cette
dimension de durabilité et comme on
contribue donc maintenant plus à
l'ephrague puisqu'on contribue aux deux
votre clair le fond de concours
aujourd'hui de l'ANC il est en déficit
depuis combien de temps donc et puis il
y a un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
ne verse pas de leur contribution
volontaire entre guillemets à la N c'est
tout ça résulte en fait d'une convention
qui a été qui a été conclue avec des
associations et il y a quelques années
euh il faut qu'on revoit ça pour pour
assurer le bon calibration en
particulier compte tenu de de des
besoins plus importants de les fringues
et aussi en fonction du troisième
des types de dépenses de ce fond de
concours qui est le financement de la
recherche puisque il y a à peu près une
centaine de milliers d'euros qui sont
qui sont mobilisés pour financer la
recherche comptable en en France il faut
peut-être se donner un plan de
développement de la recherche comptable
et et ce point-là devra on pourrait
pourraient en faire partie et donc c'est
une c'est un souci c'est un petit souci
mais c'est un souci donc ça c'est pour
le premier type de questions là là
c'est SRD il faut être clair la France
n'a pas pris le choix d'avoir une
normalisation des indicateurs de
durabilité d'avoir une normalisation
nationale elle fait le choix de prendre
le choix les normes européennes
encore faut-il mais ça ça c'est double
du coup il y a une double exigence c'est
d'abord il faut être influent au niveau
de l'Europe parce que il s'agit pas que
on laisse un et deuxièmement il faut il
faut que cette que l'écosystème français
soit bien en ligne bien aligné et bien
et que l'on est la prise en compte
complète de leurs besoins dans le
process et ça c'est un c'est un enjeu
c'est un enjeu qui jusqu'à présent a été
très bien relevé je je veux dire le
Patrick decambour a une action
extrêmement décisive dans ces dans ce
domaine là
le point qui qui que j'ai développé
peut-être c'était la fertilisation
croisée parce qu'en effet ces deux
univers sont pas des univers qui ne se
rencontrent pas d'accord d'abord tout ça
devient de la communication unique d'une
de l'entreprise ou même moment au même
moment et on voit vite qu'il y a des
interactions immédiate immédiate
d'ailleurs les les autorités la
réflexion dans ce domaine là n'en est
qu'au début il faut le reconnaître et
c'est un domaine dans lequel il faut
qu'on progresse mais on voit bien que
quand vous évaluez un actif qui soit
corporel ou incorporel savoir si cette
actif a vocation à être échoué c'est à
dire à perdre de la valeur parce que par
exemple votre plan de de sortie des des
d'un certain nombre d'activités ou de
plans de de limitation de vos émissions
carbone ou quoi que ce soit ou de
changement de fournisseur parce que
parce que le fournisseur en question ne
respecte pas un terme de choses et bien
tout ça affecte la valeur de de de de de
de vos actifs et donc il faut donc que
les deux parties cohabitent on voit bien
aussi qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
généralisation d'une on cherche à mettre
un prix par exemple sur le carbone pris
sur le carbone parce que vous êtes en
train de de vous vous avez des des
allocations de de d'émissions vous avez
des taxations dans certains dans
certains cas vous avez un marché libre
du carbone qui vous permet
éventuellement de d'afficher que vous
respectez un certain nombre d'objectifs
et bien tout ça c'est de la finance un
coût et donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
nécessité d'avoir une approche très
cohérente entre les deux c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle je crois nous
avons considéré la CRD a considéré que
il n'était pas illégitime que les gens
qui certifient qui donnent les
assurances sur les comptes financiers
soit aussi ceux qui donnent leur
assurance sur l'information de
durabilité ce qui n'était pas évident
parce que on le sait il y a autour de
ces sujets là un débat sur dites NON
l'audit c'est très concentré est-ce que
en
augmentant le périmètre dans lequel les
assurances sont demandées et compte tenu
de la
cohérence entre les deux finances et
durabilité est-ce qu'on ne va pas
renforcer la concentration du secteur
c'est donc un sujet qui est vraiment
auquel il faut être attentif et voir
comment tout cela se ce se passe alors
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que que
l'influence
de la France et de l'Union aliasb et
relativement limité c'est relativement
limité parce que
ça progresse ça progresse d'abord parce
que je crois que la France a désormais
des relations viriles mais mais réels
avec avec ISB on ne s’ignore plus on
participe à des groupes de travail
ensemble on fait partie de l'autorité de
cette de cette entité de coordination
qui s'appelle Laza avec les on est les
seuls avec le superviseur l'autorité
allemande en faire partie auprès de
auprès de auprès de l'ISB et je crois
qu'il y a SB a compris qu'elle ne
pouvait pas qu'elle ne pouvait pas
négliger la principale juridiction qui a
repris ses normes de façon obligatoire
c'est-à-dire l'Union européenne parce
que dans beaucoup de juridictions le les
normes USB sont une option
elles sont acceptées mais elles ne sont
pas obligatoires l'union et la
principale donc
il faut il faut continuer ce travail
fructueux et il faut le faire avec nos
alliés
européens d'abord et aussi dans le reste
dans le reste du monde parce qu'on a des
alignements d'intérêt parfois avec avec
d'autres autorités
puisque nous avons encore cinq questions
de nos de nos collègues alors
Eric Bocquet puis Marc Lamini
oui merci monsieur le Président bien
monsieur Opel je voudrais repartir d'une
audition que nous avions eu avec l'un de
vos prédécesseurs il y a pratiquement 10
ans maintenant 2013 Monsieur Jérôme Haas
bon malheureusement décédé l'année
suivante et il avait évoqué à l'époque
une directive un choix de l'Union
européenne appliquée en 2002 quand
l'adoption de nouvelles règles
comptables pour le contrôle des côtes
consolider des groupes internationaux et
il avait marqué la nettement la
différence dans cette évolution entre
les règles appliquées en France
cartésienne latine 1 + 1 = 2 pour faire
schématique appliquer depuis la
Renaissance et pour lui ça a marqué une
évolution énorme et je me permets de
citer une partie de son propos
compte-rendu de l'audition que vous avez
vu qui était vraiment intéressante il
nous dit ceci
pour nous le résultat c'est la
différence entre deux flux ce que l'on
dépense et ce que l'on gagne c'est
simple et sûr selon la comptabilité
internationale le résultat réside dans
la différence entre deux bilans dans
lesquels peuvent se trouver des choses
non réalisées
on n'est plus dans un monde où les
chiffres sont sûrs mais dans un monde où
ils doivent tout dire or en disant tout
ils disent également des choses fausses
ce qui n'est pas vrai c'est ce qui porte
sur l'avenir la seule chose que l'on
sage de l'avenir étant qu'on n'en sait
rien
si on comptabilise l'avenir on
comptabilise les hypothèses plus il y a
d’hypothèses moins ce que l'on dit est
crédible et tous ceux qui doivent
prendre des décisions sur cette base
risque de se tromper encore un extrait
si vous le permettez parce que vraiment
ça me paraît important cette différence
entre le réaliser le nom réalisé est un
sujet très important
là c'est lui qui parle j'ai mis un
certain temps avant de trouver que c'est
ce qui nous sépare vraiment en gros les
anglo-saxons et nous nos amis affirment
que ce qui n'est pas réalisé est très
important engagement créant des
engagements peuvent être annulés des
créances peuvent être ne pas être
recouvré ils n'ont pas tout à fait tort
de vouloir tout dire mais dire est une
chose le comptabiliser comme un résultat
en est une autre il faut selon nous
comptabiliser ce que ce qui est
effectivement dénoué c'est le Code civil
qui le dit on fait bien la distinction
entre ce qui est sûr et ce qui est
potentiel alors ça m'avait beaucoup
frappé ces propos et il faisait le lien
avec on était cinq ans après la crise
financière de 2008 là et lui faisait le
lien comme entre cette réalité de
de norme comptable et l'une des causes
importantes de la crise financière qu'on
avait vécu cinq ans auparavant alors
est-ce que cette situation est toujours
vraie vous avez parlé d'harmonisation de
résistance des États-Unis on l'entend
bien est-ce qu'on en est toujours là
où est-ce qu'il y a des travaux des
efforts pour aller vers une
harmonisation de ces normes comptables
qui devraient être selon moi planétaire
puisque aujourd'hui l'économie
financière est planétaire voire plus
merci
Eric Marc la mini puis Didier Rambaud
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à vous monsieur monsieur Opel pour
cette présentation
réellement pédagogique parce que c'est
vrai que dans l'opinion publique
beaucoup ne connaissent pas forcément
les autorités indépendantes en
particulier l'Autorité des normes
comptables
vous avez rappelé
aussi dans le sens du rapporteur notre
collègue Antoine Lefebvre
déjà sur les sur les moyens humains et
les effectifs très peu de de personnes
certes de grandes qualités une vingtaine
de
d'agences c'est très peu alors moi un
petit peu ma question c'est
bon tout est basé à Paris en région
parisienne le lien avec les victoire ou
mon jour présente un modeste département
les les Ardennes mais je pense que je
dirais quel est quel dont vos projets
sur
lors de l'exercice de vos futurs
fonctions comment s'effectuera un petit
peu le travail sur le terrain et le
maillage sur sur le territoire bon vous
avez beaucoup d'expérience aussi en au
niveau de la Banque de France qui est
aussi l'interlocuteur je dirais sur sur
le terrain du monde économique social
associatif puis également
est-ce que vous intervenez aussi en lien
parce que bon le Sénat et le
représentant des territoires et des
collectivités territoriales est-ce que
vous intervenez dans ce domaine là même
si fortement il y a une dimension
nationale européenne et internationale
forte puis également avec bon le l'Ordre
des Experts-Comptables des commissaires
au comte et autres parce qu'on
s'aperçoit même que pour toute
entreprise ou même une association qui
peut employer quelques personnes il a
une indispensable d'avoir le bilan
comptable financier etc donc ce
partenariat et le volet en direction des
associations et puis aussi peut-être un
souci de simplification sur lequel vous
vous êtes engagé également je vous
remercie merci Marc Didier Rambaud puis
Sylvie fermier
si Président Monsieur Feld dans votre
exposé vous avez parlé de ce que vous
faisiez concernant la lutte contre le
blanchiment donc du coup moi j'ai envie
de vous interpeler plus particulièrement
sur la question de la lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale je crois que
c'est des dernières années notre pays a
plutôt bien progressé à la matière
notamment la levée du Véro de Bercy qui
a renforcé donc les liens entre les
services de Bercy et la Chancellerie la
convention multi latérale à l'échelle
internationale cela étant dit je crois
que les uns et les autres on est
convaincus qui est encore beaucoup
beaucoup à faire on parle d'un chiffre
de 20 milliards d'euros de
potentiellement possible encore à
récupérer est-ce que vous partagiez ce
ce montant et sinon tout simplement tout
simplement
à votre niveau quels sont les pistes
possibles pour qu'on puisse encore
progresser à au niveau de la lutte
contre l'évasion et l'évasion fiscale et
la fraude merci
merci Didier Sylvie vermillier et
Christine Labarde merci monsieur le
président
pour la clarté de votre présentation
j'aurais une question
sur ces écarts ces divergences de normes
entre
les Français les Européens et les
Américains je prends un exemple simple
la comptabilisation du crédit-bail pour
les Français les Européens le
crédit-bail c'est un financement à part
entière les Américains savent très bien
qu'on tournait cette cette mesure ce qui
fait que le désavantage concurrentiel
entre des entreprises européennes et
américaines est important puisque du
coup
le ratio
élémentaire d'être sur capitaux propres
et considérablement modifié pour pour
certaines entreprises et voilà cette
distorsion de concurrence c'est quand
même et peut sans doute être fatale
est-ce que vous arrivez à estimer le
poids de
se désavantage concurrentiel
issus des normes alors moi effectivement
je trouve que les normes comptables
françaises ou européennes sont
logiques sont adaptés
je rejoins un petit peu l'analyse de
d'Eric Bocquet mais au bout du compte
est-ce que le préjudice est mesurable et
à quoi en étant réduit est-ce que on en
est réduit du coup dans le camp français
à courir derrière l'application des
normes américaines à s'adapter pour
lutter contre ce désavantage
concurrentiel ou est-ce qu'on continue
de vouloir valoriser notre modèle qui à
mon avis est prudentiel et
vertueux mais quelque part
voués
à ne pas à des avantager notre système
merci
Sylvie Christine Labarde merci à
Monsieur le Président avec l'adoption
par les collectivités locales de la
maquette M57 et demain
la certification des comptes des
collectivités ces dernières basculent de
plus en plus rapidement vers un système
de
reporting analogue à celui des
entreprises privées pour autant enfin je
pense que nous tous ici nous savons bien
que la comptabilité des collectivités
elle n'est pas exactement la même que
celle des entreprises et qu'il existe
notamment un certain nombre d'activités
propres collectivités que les
commissaires aux comptes ont du mal à
retracer donc comment est-ce que vous je
donne un seul exemple la par exemple les
subventions de d'investissement
aujourd'hui une entreprise doit faire
des fiches pour chaque suivre chacune
des subventions qu'elles verserait
aujourd'hui une collectivité elle est
bien incapable de faire ça je pense par
exemple aux régions sinon il va falloir
qu'on recrute moult personne pour faire
des fiches donc quel rôle allez-vous
jouer pour que les certificateurs
prennent mieux en compte cette
spécificité d'un nouvel qui rentre dans
le sphère des normes comptables
voilà monsieur le Président vous voyez
cinq questions 15 minutes
je regroupé peut-être quelques-unes
parce que il y a
il y a des questions par exemple qui
tournent autour de la du caractère un
petit peu
le lien avec les territoires et donc les
les les les collectivités locales
en effet
le tissu économique sur lequel nous
intervenons que ça soit pour les normes
nationales mais demain aussi pour les
pour les normes financières mais demain
pour les normes de durabilité il est pas
parisien il est il couvre l'ensemble du
territoire vous avez et donc comment
fait-on pour avoir les bons relais dans
les deux sens les relais c'est qu'est-ce
qui monte et qu'est-ce qu'on est
qu'est-ce qui descend c'est c'est les
deux il y a des canaux privilégiés je
dirais vous l'avez vous incite les
experts-comptables les experts
comptables sont constituent un canal
privilégié parce qu'ils sont avec les
avec aux côtés des entreprises dans les
dans dans leur activité et le deuxième
c'est aussi la Banque de France parce
que elle est présente dans les
territoires et elle fait une notation
des de beaucoup d'entreprises et dans
cette notation il y a maintenant la
volonté de prendre en compte la
dimension de durabilité aussi et ça
tombe bien parce que précisément on peut
arriver à la fois sur des normes
comptables françaises financières et sur
les indicateurs de durabilité euro
européen mais qui s'applique en France
de avoir une des relais et des échos
avec les territoires donc ça c'est c'est
très clair alors le problème des il y a
un problème je le mentionne qui est de
dire ces indicateurs de durabilité il
s'appliquent à qui
il s'applique aux entreprises mais
est-ce qu'on s'arrête aux entreprises
des collectivités vous avez cités les
collectivités territoriales qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on est sur la base de
la double matérialité qui consiste à
dire quel est l'incidence sur la valeur
financière mais aussi qu'elle est
l'impact
la double
l'impact n'étant pas il dépend pas de la
il dépend pas de la structure juridique
de la de l'entité l'impact les
collectivités territorielles ont un
impact sur les quais
qui doit être pris en compte donc il y a
un débat une réflexion à avoir pour voir
comment est-ce que tout ceci est
possible pourquoi je dis possible parce
que dans Double matérialité il y a
double mais il y a aussi matérialité
c'est à dire ce qui n'est pas matériel
on va pas il y a derrière une balance à
faire entre le coûte de de production
c'est de suivi d'un certain nombre de
d'indicateurs financiers ou ou non
financier et et et et l'intérêt qu'il y
a à le mesurer c'est à dire quel est
l'impact effectif si l'impact est
marginal on va pas on va pas le faire
donc ça c'est une c'est une dimension
extrêmement extrêmement forte il y a un
il y a une entité spécialisée sur les
les les non publics donc et qui
d'ailleurs est localisé dans le même
immeuble que la NC donc nous aurons je
n'en doute pas des débats intéressants
l'autre type de de problématique c'est
celui qu'est-ce que c'est toutes ces
normes qui ne se qui ne se qui obéissent
quelque part à des principes assez
orthogonaux d'abord il faut avoir en
tête que en Europe il y a pas de
normalisation des comptes sociaux il n'y
a pas les autres les entreprises
allemandes n'utilisent pas les normes
françaises et réciproquement et il y a
parfois des différences sensibles entre
les normes nationales ce qui veut dire
d'ailleurs que comme ces normes sont
celles qui déterminent le bénéfice
social ça veut dire que la manière dont
on détermine le bénéfice social n'est
pas identique dans tous les pays de de
l'Union alors
je disais tout à l'heure
c'est normal international qu'est-ce que
ils prennent en compte de façon
très marqué les besoins des
investisseurs c'est à dire des marchés
c'est à dire et les marchés évidemment
eux ils disent réaliser non réalisés je
suis aussi intéressé par le non réalisé
que par le réaliser
et alors pour bien comprendre le nom
réalisé il va falloir me donner des
détails très très très très très très
important donc on est dans une logique
qui est pas du tout celle du du cash du
cash flow c'est c'est une logique de la
mais il faut pas perdre de vue que à
quoi servent les comptes consolidés
les comptes qu'on se dit c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sur cette base qu'on qu'on
détermine l'imposition en France système
moniste la l'imposition il est il est
fait sur des comptes sociaux tels que
que qu'on a choisi de les de les de les
appliquer de les déterminer et qui sont
censés
retracer ce que nous pensons être la
réalité économique et donc ça peut
s'écarter de ces comptes de ces comptes
internationaux et de ses internationaux
consolidés mais dans l'objet n'est pas
exactement le même alors il est vrai que
il y a une grande après 2000 après la
crise de 2008 je dis qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces comptes qui
il faut avoir une uniformisation des
comptes internationaux qui sont
appliqués par tout le monde grand on a
essayé de rapprocher les normes et ASB
avec les normes ISB on y est pas arrivé
on y est pas arrivé et et d'abord parce
que les Américains ne souhaitent pas que
leur norme soit fixée par autre que même
donc toute façon c'est c'est un peu
compliqué et et et puis les objectifs
étaient pas exactement les mêmes et dès
qu'on rentrait dans le détail des choses
on n'arrivait pas à ce à se mettre à se
mettre d'accord mais ce qui est assez
clair et ce qui ce qui est c'est que les
normes quand c'est énorme il y a
internationale servent de base à des
réglementations
pas les comptes sociaux mais des impôts
mais réglementations ça peut poser
problème et ça peut créer des
distorsions assez fortes parce que c'est
normal international les Américains les
appliquent pas donc on part sur des
réglementations identiques mais avec des
bases de départ qui sont qui sont
différents et en effet Jérôme masse
avait bien raison il y a un problème
toujours dans ces que ça soit dans les
réglementations ou dans ces dans les
règles comptables elle-même il y a un
problème de processiclicité c'est-à-dire
est-ce que le cadre que l'on a normatif
est-ce qu'il amplifie les les les crises
alors quand on dit amplifier les crises
ça veut dire aussi en amplifier les les
booms
c'est pas symétrique mais mais quand
même mais mais
le problème c'est que les crises ont des
effets beaucoup plus graves que des que
les que les bombes or c'est vrai c'est
vrai que
c'est énorme ont une tendance à être et
d'ailleurs toutes les normes de
comptabilisation des des titres des
valeurs des opérations financières
c'était S9 a été une des une des
critiques en disant bah évidemment va
falloir de l'autre côté quand tout va
mal c'est normal de provisionner un
certain nombre de choses je donc le
problème c'est c'est jusqu'où va la
proscyclicité c'est ce qui justifie
quelque part que le président de
l'Autorité des normes comptables
et membre du Haut Conseil de stabilité
financière en France parce que
précisément on doit pouvoir essayer de
prendre en compte cette cette dimension
là qui quand on valorise au prix de
marché exacte est exacerbé est exacerbé
parce que précisément le marché a des à
des variations de prix qui sont qui sont
extrêmement fortes et qui ont tendance à
être de plus en plus fortes je je on l'a
vu et même je dirais sur des titres que
l'on pensait être beaucoup plus stable
je pense au titre d'État britannique
récemment
c'est vrai que tout ceci demande mais
l'adhésion a des normes communes et
quand même un trésor quelque part
quelques même si c'est énorme sont sont
contestables
je sais pas si j'irai j'ai pas répondu à
tout mais je crois que c'était deux
familles de questions que vous aviez que
vous aviez posé s'il n'y a pas de
regrets parmi nos collègues nous en
resterons là
monsieur le candidat encore à ce stade
pierre je fais on va vous demander on va
vous remercier d'abord votre
présentation cela a été fait
et puis également de vous répondre à nos
questions et maintenant vous demandez de
nous laisser pour que nous puissions
voter bon appétit aussi merci